[Music]
joining me today is a New York Times
bestselling author the guy who wrote
that mid-90s New York Knicks anthem a
man who has founded enterprises from
private jet companies - Zico coconut
water the co-owner of the NBA's Atlanta
Hawks and Oh a former rapper Jessie its
lair welcome to the Rubin report thanks
for having me
dude your bio is like complete doesn't
even seem like it could possibly be real
it's been a quite a journey yeah quite a
journey
alright there's so much I want to do
with you I said - you're right before we
started I mean I remember that 94 Knicks
team so well that was like right in my
formative years of basketball which I
loved I said to you right before we
started that that game six which as a
Knicks fan is probably one of the most
painful things you ever watched was the
night of my senior prom and of course
the night of the OJ Simpson car chase
you lived through that whole experience
I did I was at the knick game that night
I was at the knick game as a playoff
game I just written the theme song for
the Knicks and started was starting to
get momentum on the radio and in the
garden and I was so I mean my whole life
go up and Knick fan this was a big
moment and here we are game 6 at home
and all of a sudden the OJ chase I was
getting like a pretzel I went outside I
was everyone's looking at the monitor
and I looked up I'm like what in the
world is this oh wow so they were
showing you don't go out to the
concessions yeah yeah it was on the
monitors so you know I was conflicted
and people were running back and forth
there was wild yeah what a crazy night
because the the Rangers had just won the
Stanley Cup Finals I think and it was
just like a great time to be in New York
then OJ obviously people must have been
talking about my prom so I can only
imagine what was going on over there all
right so speaking of New York you're
from Rosalyn Long Island I'm from
Syosset Long Island we're about 10
minutes away from each other neighbors
on the Long Island Expressway I find
that a lot of interesting people come
out of Long Island have you found that
is it the water what's going on you know
it's crazy I was telling this
conversation in the day with
in mind and I was saying in my town if
you took the year that I graduated my
senior year and went back four years and
forward four years so in that eight year
gap or whatever it is from you know of
kids that went through my school we have
I think we have two with three
professional sports team owners we have
multiple billionaires I have five guys
that I went to high school is better in
jail we've had multiple suicides and
Bernie Madoff was from my town I look at
my town and think that everybody had the
same opportunity same teachers we had
one movie theater I mean it was a small
relatively small town one that one real
hot one high school that everyone went
to a real sense of community everyone
had the same basically you know journey
through with as far as teachers and
everything yeah we had this crazy swing
of the biggest Ponzi schemer and his
family and sons were in our school
you know guys that were super successful
people that had super successful parents
that went to jail I mean all in this
community it was like whoa what was in
the water yeah in this town what do you
make of that actually cuz there's got to
be something there I mean even my high
school I mean there I knew a couple
people that I went to high school with
that ended up in jail but we also had
Judd Apatow into my high school idina
menzel huge Broadway star Natalie
Portman yeah into my high school and and
all sorts of things I think that I would
feel very lucky that I grew up in the
town that I grew up in and the area that
we grew up in yeah that you know is it
was diverse there was a lot of
opportunity there was creativity it
wasn't far from the city so we had like
a little bit of a city vibe is that what
it is I think it has something to do
with the proximity because we were about
45 minutes away from New York City most
of our parents I'm guessing maybe your
parents who worked in New York City so
there was like a little bit of a
commuter thing but you weren't totally
part of New York like something related
to the neck I think that's part of it I
think for me I think it's just the time
period that I grew up you know as a kid
yeah and there was just a change in
music change in culture and we were just
exposed being close to the city we had
early exposure to all those trends
and we were early to the party and I
think that had a big impact at least it
did for me I know as an entrepreneur and
in my journey it was exciting
there was always excitement I want to be
part of everything yeah so you know I
got addicted to newness because there
was always something new going on and
that fueled me even going forward so I
feel very lucky that you know we grew up
where we did yeah anything else I should
know about your your formative years or
family before we get into some of the
things that you know well know if
there's nothing else specific you said
addicted to newness so I feel this is
the right time to play a little clip
from you as a rapper known as Jesse
James lovely
Wow oh man Jesse James that wasn't in
the in the email that you sent me about
the Shelf that you're gonna flashback we
have a pretty crack research team around
here we're going full flashback before
before we get to the future okay and the
president how did that happen
like I said grew up in Long Island in
the 80s you know when hip-hop was coming
was emerging I got really into it at an
early age and then when I was in college
you know I when everybody is writing
their resumes and sending out resumes I
was like I'm gonna try to make a record
yeah I'm like this is what I want to do
yeah and there was no B plan and
ultimately you know that passion really
for three years of college I was working
towards trying to get a record deal and
ultimately landed a deal with a company
called delicious final mountain Cali not
far from where we are and they had two
big acts of the time they had a guy
named Tony Loko yeah Wild Thing a very
old Medina and then they had it had a
little bit of a tone loke feel to it
that yeah some producers yeah and then
we had a young MC who want to grab me
for bust-a-move yeah so I was able to uh
Aksai I didn't know that but yeah
literally I was watching it this morning
and I said to David my producer that
it's not that's what it sounded like
yeah so same guys and same year a same
time yeah and put an album out in the
early 90s Wow
so I was watching and I was thinking man
time changes you know things change we
get sensitive to different things but I
would guarantee if a young guy like you
put that song out now talking about a
white woman and a white rapper we'd have
a certain amount of people screaming
about cultural appropriation and all
sorts other stuff was that anything
remotely something back then well you
know I think it was it wasn't my mind
but the shaker like a white girl was my
first single yeah was actually a remake
the title of an old EU song or no
song from watching a band in Washington
DC huh
that was predominate was all black so I
felt like I was just kind of taking the
momentum of this hit song yeah and
introducing it to the theme to you know
was fun I was in college I was I wrote
the whole album basically you know as a
fraternity in my fraternity house and
yeah it was pretty tongue-in-cheek
yeah it kind of makes you wish that
things were as simple now as they were
back then right cuz you are you
following me on this like I guess see
like some opportunity kid doing
something silly like that now and and
just like getting just like a ton of
[ __ ] for it yeah I mean if it was
totally good-natured and all that it was
totally good-natured but I look back on
it now and I think you know if I were to
go back in time I probably would do a
lot of things differently just based on
what I know now and you know I'm turning
50 so I'm very aware of you know what
chapter I on in my life but when I look
back at me at 21 and what I knew then
and you know all the mistakes I made at
21 but you know it's part of the growth
and part of the journey yeah
alright so I want to get to some of the
growth in the journey I want to get a
book and all that stuff but wait let's
just jump back to the to the go New York
go New York go thing yeah how in the
world did that even appear that you were
gonna be the guy that wrote that thing
and were you shocked that it caught on I
mean the video which will will also link
through down below I like I remember
every moment of that so what happened
for me is right after college no resume
you know got rejected by a lot of record
labels I had no contacts my dad on the
plumbing supply house in Mineola also
not free I wasn't right there we had I
didn't know anyone that was connected to
anything so I had to take this whole
this whole process on my own shoulders
and I would literally take a Greyhound
bus on Friday from Washington DC where I
went to school with my demo tape which
was a recording of an instrumental that
I played on my CD player and I would hit
record on my answering machine and leave
a rap to the music while it was playing
that was out the only way I could man
unbelievable sound like a time warp I
know that's that was the only way I
could do it no I would show up and hand
out
that cassette to everybody and got
rejected but ultimately I did get a
record I get to get a record deal and
but that was my only goal so I took my
foot off the gas pedal once I got the
deal and I didn't get signed for a
second album which to me was crushing at
the time because the only thing on my
resume now was you know failed rapper
yeah you know it was also a kiddie pool
attendant before there so that wasn't
really gonna get me a job on watch me
that's like a low-level life their
training and walk no peeing that was if
you could say walk and stop stop peeing
you could get the job they're always
peeing on that there always be there's
nothing get him out of there but in any
event I wanted to stay even though I
didn't get picked up for a second album
I wanted to marry my two passions which
was sports and music and I had this idea
to write a theme song for the Knicks I
was like all of a sudden sports were
changing the game is only 48 minutes and
you're there you're a fan for 48 minutes
but for the other two hours that you're
in the arena during timeouts you're an
audience yeah and the teams had to
entertain the audience and now they
brought in the dancers the Knicks City
Dancers came in and they had video
boards that all of a sudden never
existed so let's do a theme song like
the Bears did a song in 86 oh yeah let's
do a theme song we'll get all the
celebrities involved and and maybe it'll
catch on so I wrote this demo basically
in my apartment which was like a dorm
room and I played it for the Knicks and
how'd you even get that meeting I
hearted doing jingles and somehow I did
a jingle for Nancy grünfeld
clothing company her husband Ernie was
the GM uh-huh and she loved the jingle
and I said well Nancy if you love this
let's let's do something for the next
let's try this
so she said I'll take a shot at it so I
just did it on spec I walked in and I
knew it there was something there yeah
and I played it for them and they said
you know we'll give you a $4,000 for the
song and I said okay I hired a write
down in there you said okay right then
and there
oh yeah no lawyer nothing doc I didn't
ask any questions up for
dollars whose 8 months of rent yeah so I
when I hired a lawyer ultimately any
lawyer studio engineer singer drummer
producer etc it cost me 48 hundred
dollars to do this song but every team
that came into Madison Square Garden
said why don't we have a theme so uh
this and the Knicks got hot and it
became the number one most requested
song that little jingle on New York
radio and I realize like that's the
white space nobody else is everyone's
trying to get on MTV and get their
records and Tower Records but no there's
a category a new category that I could
create sports music and I started doing
theme songs for professional sports
teams yeah it's so awesome like it's
just such a great story of just like a
kid basically a kid just like it oh no
just get out there and do something it's
kind of a kind of a beautiful thing you
must look at it back I can see sort of
in your face like there's like a
nostalgia to it cuz it was just like I
just what it was
I look at it from that chapter of my
life where I had 21 years old there were
no consequences like if I didn't get
this song I would have gone to the next
team and kept I was so deeply connected
to my dream they're emotionally
connected to the goal that I was on a
Greyhound bus every day try I mean I
would do anything so just to have the
opportunity that it was just everything
else was gravy yeah so is that really
where the entrepreneurial spirit started
with you because it seems like you got
that going and then that opened up a
whole slew of other doors that opened up
the floodgates for some big for some big
futures you know successes and failures
but I was thinking about this actually
yesterday on a run you know I used to
you'll probably remember I don't know if
you're into tennis yeah but the US Open
was right by you know you can take our
yeah flushing yes we would just take the
train you know my there were no rules my
parents also by 8 o'clock at night yeah
I would take the the train and I
remember I would never have a ticket and
all I could look I would look forward to
being able to try to sneak into the US
Open and I remember though that I've
kind of figured out how to sneak into
the US Open regularly so I would go no
ticket everyone's online and I would go
to like how I went in
and then I would walk out and see if I
could do it again someone else that was
really the start of like as I look back
like I just want I like challenges yeah
it doesn't there's not about anything
other than can I figure it out and and
it started for me at an early age and
ultimately it gravity you know I started
to gravitate towards business yeah so
let's let's get there so okay you're
making the jingles some things happen
you're obviously making money probably
some serious money for the first time
how does this get you to starting
incubators and starting these companies
so I'm so all the soap so every team
that came into Madison Square Garden
said why don't we have a song like this
who did this yeah and I was a guy so I
started writing all these team songs and
ultimately sold though that company to a
public company called SFX and the owner
of SFX had a timeshare in a private jet
and he invite was like 26 years old my
he invited my partner and I as guests
onto his private jet it was like the
scene in The Wizard of Oz when we walked
on the plane when everything goes from
black and white on the plane I'm like
people fly like this yeah and by the
time we land in my partner turned to me
is like we had to start a private jet
company so we can fly around on these
planes and I was like let's do it that's
hilarious and that's literally how we
started this company that ultimately be
caught I was called marquee jet yeah
that became the largest private jet card
company in the world so you eventually
sold the company it's called nest yet it
was called marquee jet I saw the two
warren buffett's burnett jets which is a
berkshire hathaway company yeah and then
so then now you're rolling in dough it
was it was a change definitely a
life-changing moment for me yeah but
again I love newness and I was at that
time in my life I just ran a hundred
mile run for charity and I gave myself
90 days to train for it and during the
process of my training I discovered
coconut water because I did a lot of
research around hydration and nutrition
if you're gonna run 24 you know 100
miles non-stop yeah would eat what do
you drink and how many calories do you
take in and
you're experimenting with that with that
now through your new diet without going
through but I discovered coconut water
and which ultimately you know I fueled
me for this race that I completed and
when I was done I was like man this is
the Fountain of Youth this is gonna be
the next big thing in beverage you know
it's like this is the next orange juice
mrs. Nick's pom wonderful and I spent a
year traveling the globe trying to
figure out how to import coconut water
or what yours is this is 2007 2007 so
like no honey because it's not that long
ago and yet coconut water is so massive
right now you'd think this would have to
be 25 years ago right but in 2007 I was
even on the chef there was one SKU on
the shelf yeah it wasn't didn't really
exist but I realized that the learning
curve I got like a 980 I'm SAT the
learning curve was 1200 okay alright we
were um old ones I should have called
you I couldn't figure it out man I'm
like I know I can market this but like I
don't know how I'm gonna import this as
so many moving pieces so I ended up
partnering with the company that was you
know on the scene called Zico just doing
a couple million dollars in sales yeah
and then ultimately two years later we
sold it to coke so then then you're
really in the business world like at
that point you've sold to companies and
and you're rolling how do you then go
alright
I like newness what's new after this
because that's what your story seems to
be it's just like another what's new
what's new what's new what's new I get
bored easily and I just you know I
believe in checking the box and like not
celebrating what happened happened
what's next and you know my whole thing
I always talked about this it's just
about building my own personal life
resume not even my business resume and
like I love adventure so I was just
looking for you know whatever that next
opportunity was and it became it was not
for me at in the timeline of my life the
next thing was a book but it wasn't
planned yeah I wasn't planned let's
let's talk about that book a little bit
before we get to this book yeah I was at
a at a race 24 hour race I love
endurance I participated a lot of
endurance events and the race was was a
really really format so I was with five
friends and each runs a mile and you
rotate and whatever
runs the most amount of miles in 24
hours wins the competition but at the
start of the race there was a guy
sitting next to us that no one really
with he had no teammates he was his own
team uh-huh
and he waited like 285 pounds just big
african-american guy just sitting in a
chair everything myself how in the world
is a guy that weighs 285 could have run
for 24 straight hours and the race was
on are you even allowed they let you run
a relay one guy he was like the only
solo you know by himself and it was just
like and I was just so big and
intimidating and the race was
unsupported so they they provide nothing
it was on a dirt one mile unlit parking
lot and you hadn't even bring your own
water I mean they gave you nothing
mmm so I had just sold my company I like
I went crazy and I said masseuses a
table fed up like I said this guy had
three items a box of crackers a fold-up
chair and a bottle of water and I was
like man half this isn't gonna work out
well and sure enough at mouth 70 he
because of his weight he had broken
multiple bones and both of his feet he
crushed the bones and his feet from just
the pounding because he was just so big
and because he only had water and
crackers he had kidney failure and he
was peeing blood down his leg and my
first reaction is when we got to get
this guy a medic immediately like
airlift him out of here to a hospital
yeah but what did he do he gets out of
the chair picks himself up runs another
30 miles to get to his goal of 100 and
then runs one more in case they miss
counted and I mean it was like man I
gotta I gotta meet this guy I gotta meet
him because whatever secret sauce he has
like whatever Drive he has to get him
out get him out of the chair you don't
even get a ribbon yeah first finish like
they they pat you on the back good job
there's no trophy you don't get extra
crackers no this is like you go home and
that's that whatever got him out of the
chair if I could teach that to my kids
if I could apply that drive to the
multiple buckets of my life then all the
areas of my life would be so much better
so I ended up call you know googling on
founding out he was a Navy SEAL I call
call them and we sat down for
lunch and I realized I would never get
the secret sauce in a lunch meeting and
just asked him like would you come live
with me for a month and he said to me
basically direct quote if you're crazy
enough to ask a guy like me to come live
with you
[ __ ] I'm crazy enough to come
and that was the start of our journey so
you spent how much time with this kind
of month yeah he came and moved into
with my wife Sarah myself and at the
time my son I had one child we should
mention his name because let's give him
the credit David Goggin yeah okay David
Goggins he's an amazing human yeah an
American and with an amazing story
came in live with a my wife and I and my
son for 18 for 30 days what did your
wife think about this not bringing a
Navy SEAL in for a month she called me
after the lunch meeting and she said you
know how did it go and I said very
quickly he's on a little bus yeah what
you know like got into a big fuss I said
no he's actually sweet he's coming to
live with us on Friday and no I mean she
once he came in they immediately you
know took to each other and it was just
an amazing journey and I never thought
the notion of writing a book never
crossed my mind in fact the book came
out the book living with the seal came
out five years after he actually lived
with us because as I started to put some
of the tools that I I learned and what I
learned about myself and about his
mindset into action and share with
others I was like well there's a there's
something here yeah and that's sort of
how it came to fruition yeah let's
explore some of that stuff so he gets to
your house first day like did you have a
plan or were you just like take over man
you got a month like make me better I
said to him make yourself at home is the
first thing I said to him and I said you
know our home is your home
and he walked right over to me and he
said I don't have a home that's a no
make yourself at home is just an
expression and again he got a little
closer like nose to nose and he said I
don't operate in expressions that's like
okay it's gonna be a great little great
30 day house guest Wow
and it's in fact get your stuff on let's
go see where you're at physically we'll
go down
the gym so I can map out the month and
when he came to live with us at that
time in my life I was in a great spot
you know I was married I'm still married
they had just had a child I now four
just had some failure had some success
but I was in I thought I was in a really
good spot but like so many of us I was
in a routine now it was really
comfortable in my routine my routine was
get up work out hard go to work all day
come home have some dinner with my wife
and child a little bit alone time repeat
and like I thought I was operating up
here mm-hmm but I was so comfortable I
couldn't get out of it and like you
routines are great but they can also be
a rut mm-hmm and like I realize like I
don't go through life like this like I
wanna go through life like this yeah I
got to get out of my routine man
otherwise I'm gonna wake up and I'll be
70 so you think that that routine even
when it's all going well and it sounds
like things were going pretty well for
you that no matter what that that level
of routine will automatically stifle
creativity without question and and time
goes fast like I've four kids I want to
slow the clock down yeah and if I'm in
routine and you're in routine you miss a
lot of opportunities at least for me
that's the way I found my life to unfold
and I feel like when I step out of
routine you know when I go into the
unknown
that's where amazing growth happens and
that's where I feel most alive and
that's where I get the most benefit and
that's why I check the box and move on
mentality and that's what this
opportunity was for me nothing other
than to you know to step into the
unknown he represented unknown and and a
little bit of secret sauce so we go down
to my gym and you know he's like let me
see how many poets you could do so I got
up and I you know I can run pretty far
in a circle or a straight line for a
long time but not really strong so I did
like I'd like ain't pull-ups which is an
exaggeration yeah yeah yeah oof all
right and then he sorry wait 30 seconds
and do it again so I got back on the
barn I did again like one or two or
something you know barely he said wait
30 seconds I want you to do it again and
now like my arms and I can get back on
the bar I'm trying to get my
chin up over the bar and I dropped down
and and I said I well what's next and he
said well what's next is we're not
leaving here until you do a hundred more
Jesus Christ and I said like that's
impossible I can't do 100 and he said to
me well I already know what your biggest
problem is but probably with all of our
biggest problem is and he said the
limitations that you're putting on
herself that we put on ourselves are
self-imposed and I'm gonna prove it to
you so get back up on the [ __ ] bar
and give me a pull up so I did a pull up
and I dropped down and and I repeated
that process until I did all hundred
holy and I realize like oh it took like
two hours but I realized at that moment
that I found under indexing by a hundred
pull-ups mm-hmm like what are the areas
of my life and my other indexing it you
know
am i under indexing at work with my wife
and my relationships am i comfortable am
I in this routine I mean I just didn't
want to go to that place of pain to see
what I was really made of and that
started our journey and that was a
constant theme of like how far can you
take this Jessie like you know why are
you holding yourself back and not just
physically but in in everything and work
okay we've had some success but how do
you know your limits it's like when I
started running my goal was to run two
miles if I could run two miles in 18
minutes I consider myself a runner
mm-hmm and that was it I worked hard to
get took me weeks to go from the couch
to those two miles there's a lot of
people with a gun to their head that can
run two miles right now nothing changed
in my body since then same leg same long
as God gave me same I'm not really
strong but I was able to take that same
body God gave me from two miles and
ultimately take it to a hundred miles
without stopping and the only thing that
changed was what I thought I could do
mm-hmm so if I was under indexing 50 X
in that area again what are my limits in
business what are my limits in my life
resume and how I live my life and what
are my limits and how deep my
relationships can be and what are my
limits
how much I can learn and we're travel or
anything yeah so I think it's probably
easy for people at some level to
understand the quantifiable stuff I can
run faster I can lift more that kind of
stuff can you talk about it sort of on
the mental side on the relationship side
like how do you actually judge what are
the right ways to to spread yourself in
those areas sure well I mean I think
that I think for me I think a lot of
people we think about relationships we
think of relationships between people
how was your relationship with your
parents or your child or your husband or
wife or whatever it is and I think one
thing that's often very neglected is our
relationship with time and talk about
quantifiable stuff and I'm very aware of
my relationship with time that's been a
fundamental shift for me over the last
couple of years and maybe because I've
turned 50 but I was recently on a
camping trip you look like you're 28
doing something right it's Long Island
but I was recently on a camping trip and
I was with a friend of mine as a police
officer in Suffolk County County he had
his daughter I had my son and we went on
a cold winter Mount Washington blizzardy
outdoors sleeping in the snow camping
trip and I turned to him I said Kevin
how often do you truck do trips like
this this is a guy that's a police
officer you know one of the happiest
guys I know probably not super well-off
I mean you know blue-collar guy
extremely happy and he says I think he
said every year I take it one trip a
year with my college friends I've been
doing it to some 21 years old then every
other month I take a trip with my family
or myself it could be run a marathon it
could be go to the lake it could be
going to hike whatever and I said to
myself if I can take I call it Kevin's
rule one weekend every eight weeks for
my own adventure with my family with
friends and it doesn't have to be
something that cost a lot of money but
if I can't think five or six of those a
year mm-hmm
then I'm Way out of balance so it might
not be a direct answer to your question
but what I'm saying is you know you
could in the past maybe I'll be one or
two
times a year and I wouldn't even be
aware of it mm-hmm but once you become
aware of it look over the next 30 years
you're talking about a hundred and fifty
memories you know it's all cumulative
yeah as opposed to maybe 20-30 memories
that's the difference of like a really
full life it could be at the end of the
day with no regrets you know with no
regrets versus someone that's in their
routine going through life like this and
then you wake up and you're 75 you know
like [ __ ] I don't have the energy to go
to Mount Washington anymore I don't have
my son my kids are grown up so those
kind of shifts are measurable and I can
pinpoint it in time I can pinpoint it in
my relationship with my wife and just
Friday night dinners Wednesday night
date night it's just what's your
relationship with time how do you spend
it who do you spend it with and are you
doing the things you love to do yeah
well that's definitely a good segue to
living with monks so quickly though do
you have some of those people in your
life what Kevin just said about
reconnect with the high school friends
and that because I find now a couple of
my most valuable relationships that I
have right now are with one of them's
might my childhood best friend since um
since we were four years old I remember
meeting the guy and in kindergarten
where I think it maybe it was the day
before kindergarten and then another
friend from third grade and we've stayed
connected and because of that it helps
me frame the future because we've been
having these same conversations about
love and life and sports and politics
forever and it's like watching us all
you know one of them lives in Jersey
ones in Texas and I'm here in LA and yet
our journeys they still matter to each
other so I think it helps like set the
future sort of yeah I'm fortunate that I
do I'm so you know so so of the same
high school friends and friends from my
neighborhood when I grew up still super
close to and I think you're right you
know we're so lucky to have that yeah
and it's you know so a big part of my
life that those relationships and also
you know they can relate to the
backstory very often if I meet someone
now they know Jesse at 50 they don't
know Jesse at 6 and Roz and little even
Jesse you know you know we probably all
you're a couple years older ya say we
probably played Little League against
each other but you got a couple years on
me right right but same thing yeah so I
agree with you I agree with you and but
you know I I think all of my friends
from from high school and even college
and even today I mean they invest time
in keeping those relationships so and
you can do it easily now from Facebook
and social media and this kind of stuff
but often we don't but I'm fortunate
that my group of friends we do you know
we had for a while with a newsletter
that we put together for each other and
it makes me smile I just thought about
it now you know I mean just feel really
lucky all right so let's shift to your
new book living with the monks I want to
get the the subtitle totally right here
because I love it
what turning off my phone taught me
about happiness gratitude and focus so
we are taping this right now we're
holding it for a little bit because I
want to air this right before I go off
the grid cuz my audience knows I do this
August off-the-grid thing literally lock
my phone and is safe no phone no TV no
electronics no nothing I'm gonna work on
my book a little bit I'll probably
escape to a beach for a little bit I'm
not even totally sure what I'm gonna do
but just get off the endless information
grid so before we talk about me and why
I think it's good to do that what led
you to wanting to do this at first place
well I'd spent I'd invested so much in
the physical side for my whole life
you know running marathons and doing
endurance events and had a Navy SEAL
move in with me but I really had felt
like I had neglected the inner side and
just the inner work and I was just going
so fast so I felt - really again maybe
I'm turning older I don't know but to
get the whole package or that what I
want and be is well-rounded I really
needed that side there's the spiritual
side and and I was just thinking like
well who would be the best teacher and I
thought monks and I didn't know anything
about monks other than like watching
some movies right
you know fringe articles here and there
I thought that'd be really cool to learn
it
you know the traditions and how monks
live their lives and doing exactly what
you said you know I'm I'm bombarded by
information mm-hmm and I don't spend any
time alone and when you don't spend time
alone you lose your superpower you use
your intuition because you're being
influenced by everybody else and you
wanna exercise your gut muscle I was
losing my superpower
so I said to Sarah I think I want to go
and was there a moment that you really
felt that you had lost it or that you
could really recognize that you lost it
cuz I think a lot of people walk around
with that all the time now I felt just
because the endless social media you're
so hit with stuff constantly
that it does make your your sort of
inner monologue sort of harder to listen
to because it's just being slammed in
every which direct it wasn't buildup
I just felt so distracted yeah and you
know we all feel overwhelmed I mean but
I felt really distracted and I felt like
you know four kids a job I married
friends my parents are getting older I
mean all these different things and then
all these different social media things
and news and Netflix and Hulu a little
bit of like I just want to like I got it
I would just feel alone and so was it
build up and then I mean my wife and I
were talking about it and so they just
wanted I'm gonna go and live on a
monastery and she was super encouraging
you know and she was like so so that's
what happened so what do you do you give
a call you yells yelping yeah yes sirree
no I am I actually found this monastery
through a friend of mine who's actually
my publisher and I went to a monastery
with eight monks which already was a
misconception for me because I thought
monastery meant community meant hundreds
but there were eight monks at this
particular monastery for which had been
there for 50 years
Wow and they lived on 500 acres in the
States but in isolation 500 acres and
similar to what you're about to do in
August or now yeah you know no phone no
internet no news no this no that and I
just took 15 days to decompress so what
was it like so you get there day one
I mean what was the most shocking part I
got since you're a pretty open guy so
there was probably not much that could
shock you but like what do they say do
they like take all your stuff like first
of all they were Russian Orthodox they
weren't Buddhists okay so like that
arete I didn't I had no expectation of
anything and I walked into my room which
they call cell that's the rooms are
called self and monastery look and it
was the size of this carpet like where
we are and I had a bed one little desk
with a light and brother Christopher who
was like my go-to monk sat me down and
he said tomorrow at 7 a.m.
we'll start with prayer reflection and
meditation and I said ok it's 6:00 p.m.
what do I do
13 hours and he looked at me and he said
you think and I said ok and he left the
room and I realized like I can't call my
wife I can't there's no books in my room
I mean they had books but there are no
books there's no like it's super like
eerie quiet yeah and I'm like all right
I'm gonna meditate let me start the
journey
I took a TM Transcendental Meditation
course mm-hmm
set my timer for 20 minutes I sat in my
chair and I started to close my eyes
focused on my mantra and I'm getting
bombarded over how are my kids my wife
you know the Hawks are gonna be what are
we gonna do this you know everything in
my head and we will talk about the Hawks
board oh by the way I'm sitting and I'm
going and I'm like why isn't my beeper
beep because I've been here forever
yeah and I'm like I probably just
started so I let me just keep going keep
going and finally there's no beep and I
said well let me just reset my beeper
and I'll start over no I go back that
would be cheating anyway I'm in my chair
forever and I finally like this is
ridiculous I'll just let me reset this
and start this again I open up my eyes I
look at my time or 3 minutes and 27
seconds Wow
and I strongly calculated how many
minutes I had left on the monastery I
did 15 days times 24 times and I was
like I just said to myself I'm [ __ ]
like that this is this is great on paper
yeah in theory but this is gonna be
[ __ ] hard yeah and I just sat in my
room and I was like oh my god what'd I
get myself into were you allowed to
leave the room I could leave the room
yeah
I couldn't leave the property this is
the craziest situation so yeah the monks
to keep the lights on at the monastery
they breed German Shepherds so there are
11 adult German Shepherds 8 monks and me
so they're selling German Shepherds yes
this is all puppies yeah
that's any trained dogs they're world
renowned dog trainers well they've
written books they've sold millions of
copies of books they're just it's just a
really unusual scenario so yes I could
leave my cell yeah and walk around the
monastery but first of all it's 4
degrees outside it's there's no lights
it's like pitch dark at 4 o'clock right
it's freezing there's bear according to
the monks like so no I really could
leave them right so I mean I just kind
of like I ended up walking 120 miles up
and down the driveway they had because I
had to get some exercise over the course
of my journey but I didn't leave mm-hmm
so I just sat there and you know the
first five this five days was really
really difficult for me and I started
immediately doing probably what I think
most people do certainly what I do I
started giving myself an out I started
justifying that it would be okay to go
home early mm-hmm yes seven days man
that's enough get out of here in seven
days no one's gonna say oh you didn't do
whatever just and I started creating all
these excuses in my head and I started
thinking myself like what are the goals
do I have in areas of my life and my
giving excuses in you know and really
started to like analyze everything that
was going through my head and put it
into the real my real world yeah and I
just saw a lot of things about myself
you know through that through just being
quiet and alone how did you break
through that moment if I can get away
with seven days here
like what was the actual thing that
turned down that I have a to words that
changed my life that I refer back to all
the time and though when I wanted to go
home those two words were like I signed
up for 15 days that's what that's what
this goal was 15 days day five when I
really want to go home and I missed my
kids and I couldn't call you know the
two words are remembered tomorrow when
you have a big split-second decision or
a big major decision how how is that
decision gonna make you feel tomorrow so
I said to myself if I drop out and quit
now the one time I'm gonna do this in my
life how am I gonna feel about this
tomorrow when I get home when someone
says how'd you do did you make it
terrible you know if I my legs are
swollen at Mile 18 I want to drop out of
the race so the marathon but I want to
come home the next day after the New
York Marathon did you finish
so remember tomorrow yeah so I just kind
of said that to myself over and over
like just remember how you gonna feel
about this and remember how plowed
you're gonna feel at the end of the
journey and before I went my wife said
don't leave until you have a
breakthrough you're broken and I'm like
I'm not broken and I haven't had a
breakthrough I'm saying so did you get
broken or have a breakthrough you know
it's funny fact I know the answer at
least I want had some breakthroughs for
sure but I never felt broken and I think
I think the reason I never felt broken
is because it had definitive end date
yeah so broken for you would have been
like I'm leaving anyway like yeah it
would had to really take me to a place
of you know yeah yeah I mean I had
moments of being broken and super sad I
mean you know like when you're away from
everything and you don't know what's
going on you just don't know you don't
know God on my kids getting bullied is
something happening is my wife okay you
know is the world in risk is you just
don't know huh and you start to imagine
that the world's gonna head I think the
your brain automatically goes to the
worst it doesn't go to everything it's
great it's like Oh
I should have been so much nicer to my
wife because I'm gonna go there she's
not gonna be home when I get home yeah
like we started thinking [ __ ] like that
yeah and then you spirals because you
have energy and space to think and
imagine and dream and a vision and all
the [ __ ] that's like it all comes to the
surface and you know because it's in the
real world if you're having a tough day
you could say to Dave you guys good you
know what let's put on movie in Netflix
and just so [ __ ] escape and sit down
you order Chinese food and you have your
Netflix and your watch but guess what
the issues don't go away mm-hmm when the
movies over that [ __ ] is still there
every on your to-do list they're still
there when I'm watching them right
they're still there yeah and you know
this forced you there was no escape
mm-hmm this was your escape so it forced
me to have to think through stuff and I
got a lot of clarity you know it's funny
although this is in no way comparable
when I did my off-the-grid thing last
year and after a week we were 10 days or
so we were in Mexico and I just I just
needed to do nothing I just needed to
wake up every morning have a light
breakfast I went to the gym and then I
would just sit I got the same seat at
the beach every day and I would just sit
and stare at the ocean for hours really
for hours and I do a little try to do a
little meditation and stuff but I did
have that moment at one point where I
was like anything could be happening
right now like World War three could be
starting there you know the terror
attacked like but you know zombie
apocalypse like where you go to like the
craziest [ __ ] and then I remember
thinking I was like you know you go
there for a while and then I suddenly
got to the end of it and I was like well
nothing I could do about it right now so
I better reset - yes - this better place
and there's a real discipline in that in
how you can control your mind and your
thoughts
I think the for sure the first three or
four days there I was obsessed with my
to-do list and by day four or five I'm
like if a hurricane came and whisked my
to-do list into the ocean life goes on
like oh okay yeah and you know I was I
was like a captive to my to-do list
because you know I'm always and it's my
to-do list for me wasn't even about
finishing that the tasks
as good as I could possibly do him it
was about finishing him so I could keep
it felt so good to cross him off that
even if it was 70% to what I could
probably do it on to the next on to the
next on to the next at the monastery the
the mostly to-do list
there was no to-do list mm-hmm it was
whatever is in front of me yeah is my
task at hand so tell me a little bit
just sort of what that day looks like so
you get up the next morning now it's day
2 so Dave said did you say 7 a.m. or 6
a.m. 7 a.m. and then prayer start yes so
they would ring a big a big like noted
Notre Dame you know church bell louder I
was right next to which was the which
signal to go to the to the church where
they would have a about an
hour-and-a-half
service which was meditation reflection
service what was it religious in anyway
yeah they were Russian Orthodox yeah it
was it was a religion it was religious
for me it was it was peaceful uh-huh
but it was definitely definitely
religious and then and then we would
shift to breakfast which was
traditionally silent most of those
breakfast the breakfast were silent and
that would go to let's say 9:30 or 10:00
and afterwards there'd be a little bit
of a long time and then it would go to
tasks and each of the monks would have a
different responsibility which was just
unbelievably efficient and I spent each
day shadowing a different monk so I got
two rounds basically and then there
would be supper dinner was lunch time so
they flip-flop so breakfast was a really
light meal which for me is just fruit
then lunch their lunch was dinners that
would be the big meal mm-hmm rest well
it's like sleepaway camp you go that's
rest time we'll see us then more labour
yeah which could be cleaning the church
doing some whatever the everyone's tasks
were yeah they always have stuff to do
cause it's like it's kind of funny like
if you think about it like all right so
eight guys living at this place we're
always doing stuff oh it seems like
there wouldn't be that much more to do
you know because you don't want to know
why if the toilet breaks they don't call
plumber yeah I fixed the toilet they
built the monastery by hand they every
thing is they do everything right well
let's get a swimming pool okay get a
shovel you get a shovel you get a shovel
you know let's figure out how to do it
you know and we'll build a shovel this
wonderful piece so they do I'd probably
hire you for a couple job supervisor and
then and then we would there was just
more time alone so there was a
tremendous amount of time yeah but also
from a lot of work so talk a little bit
about the disconnecting from technology
I get the concerns about your wife your
kids things like that how did you feel
about not putting your hand in your
pocket to go to your phone or not having
an iPad right in front of you or
television screen or the rest of it you
know it's funny because when I got back
everybody asked me well would you miss
and the obvious answer is I miss my
family and this and that but no one ever
asked me what didn't you miss and what I
didn't miss at all were things that I do
every day that I thought I wouldn't miss
for example I went during the NCAA
tournament I didn't miss not watching
March Madness been a something I love to
do forever and if I calculated how many
hours of basketball I've watched yeah
that's like you know five years of my
life but I didn't miss it and I didn't
miss hitting like that you know liking
my friends picture in Cancun with with
you know they did with a corona yeah I
didn't miss any of that stuff I didn't
miss going through Hulu and Netflix and
debating with my wife what to watch and
I realized I spent a lot of time on
things that I really didn't miss and if
I eliminated some of those I would freed
up a lot more time to spend to do the
things I love to do with people I love
to do them with yeah so but it was it's
a ring of so comfortable with my phone's
always in my hand it was hard man really
hard it took it took a long time to get
to ask that did you feel that there was
like a little bit of a learning curve
with it like when I did it and as I said
I locked my phone and a safe I did not
know the code and I found that for the
first day or two I kept going in my
pocket even at the beach like I'm just
going to but there's nothing in my
pocket I don't even think my shirts had
pockets so I was just like going like
this and then there's like this weird
anxiety of like what's going on what did
I
zombie apocalypse or the war started
whatever and then suddenly by day like
five I kind of felt empowered by day
eight I was like I want nothing to do
with that then maybe there's a little
bit of like a return to uh it'll be okay
I'll manage it differently did you go
through all of those s the exact steps
you just mentioned in the exact
timeframe you just then once I got to
the point where I didn't miss it where
the habit of checking before I went to
bed or waking up at 5:00 in the morning
and seeing anything new come in through
you know the words
once I got past that yeah I just I
didn't miss it I didn't want it you know
and once I got home and I put on the
news and read you know like what's going
on in the world and all the negative
stuff it was just like uh but Here I am
I've been home you know I'm back on my
phone I came home I'm like I'm off email
right and then you know but you drift
back so have you been able to put any
kind of just personal policies in place
to manage this stuff because I'm still
trying I don't do phone in bedroom 90%
of the night every now and again it's
just somehow ends up there but like
that's one for me so that at five am I
just don't do that
yeah I never you know 11 the obvious
ones you know no not not in the bedroom
not at Meal Time not at movies I'm at
Isis it in movies and I heard a ding or
a beep or a buzz yeah I go into my shirt
and look like you know I look under here
but now so there's so I became this is
the I think this will summarize my
experience the best they had a retreat
at the monastery I made all these guests
and when the guests left they said to me
Jesse
you're gonna clean up all the dishes
like the like the rookie on the team
okay
there's 500 dishes stacked so I started
cleaning the dishes I'm drying I'm and
cleaning up and drying them and they go
and they bring more in and I turned him
I'm like I'm this gonna take me forever
how am I gonna do all these dishes and
one of the most certainly goes there's
not all those dishes there's only the
dish that's in your hand and I was like
it reminded me that I'm never where my
feet are and I got to be where my feet
are you know
is what I'm doing yeah there's something
there because I do find that I actually
like doing the dishes I know that's a
little nuts and I'm not doing it I'm not
doing it for 500 people but I do find
it's like one of like I can't have my
phone in my hand while I'm doing the
dishes right like I it's one little
thing that you're doing right there so I
do find on these brief moments that you
know you know I'm on tour right now and
it's like when I'm doing this when I
have these brief moments I like doing
like very menial like I really like
gardening or just like cleaning up
outside or like these things that aren't
much because they seem to have this this
incredible importance we've lost touch
with a lot of those things that help us
feel connected you know like we have no
connection to our food we go to a
supermarket no unless you live on a farm
like we're very disconnected from a lot
of things that make us tick and simple
things like that bring us back down to
earth and they go around us and I felt
the same way I felt as a contributor
even if it's contributing to your own
household you know and as opposed to
having someone to come and clean it or
however you guys do it or whatever but
it makes you feel connected important
part of it and it creates momentum and
wins I can't explain it but I felt the
same way I loved it I was volunteering
for it yeah yeah there's real value in
that like even when you came into my
house and you were me like oh it's so
great here and it's not it's like I
really love like we put a lot of effort
yeah it's like I want to like wake up in
the place that I want to be at and like
make it better and make it more valuable
all that so for the average person that
can't maybe go take a month to do this
what's the piece of advice or can people
do a weekend with monk's can you do it
can you just do a day with bugs I mean I
think it listen I think I think anyone
can spend time alone yeah I think
spending time alone and you reckon I
recognize like I don't spend any time
alone other than going for runs which is
you know but I think it's really
important because I think the only way
you can really be in tune with your gut
is to be is to spend some time alone so
I think that's really important I think
for me I carry a lot of stuff in my head
I realized that I need to like I put
everything on paper now I get out of my
head it doesn't disappear but it frees
up space you know
I had a lot of space and creative energy
at the monastery because I didn't have I
wasn't cluttered so now I have a two
journal system that I use it's very
simple I dump everything into one big
journal doesn't go away but it's out of
my head yeah I don't have to remember I
have to get a kid a birthday present or
whatever and then I make my daily kind
of routine and this kind of thing and
yeah I think just being really aware of
where your feet are is is really
important I mean the monks are mano
tasker's I live in a world of
multitasking yeah and I think that you
know for the everyday for everybody I
think that feels overwhelms or filled
that feels distracted is to do one thing
at a time and do it well and move on
have you been back to the monastery
since I'm going to go I have in the back
what I thought finally going to go back
to partaking ITER's it's like can you go
like this and leave like just for some
high fives yeah I'm act like they're
down for that sort of thing like I think
- - yeah for some high fives I guess
you'll find out I mean I was like an
alien I came in there I was full energy
I'm like what are we running did they
have any idea of your history or just
that you know that your successes any of
that stuff they just think it's just
some guy yeah we're landing on this
I remember that must've been pretty cool
in and of itself I remember very clearly
sitting down I was telling about my
journey I was talking about coconut
water and they all looked at me and said
what's coconut water I was talking about
the Atlanta Hawks and one of them raised
their hand said I went to an Expos game
Wow in Montreal and I'm like that's
baseball anymore yeah
all right well further our last few
minutes let's talk about the Hawks for a
second and just oh you own a basketball
team which to me is as you know I love
basketball like that's like the greatest
thing on earth like if I I would
probably stop doing all this - I would
traded in tow in a basketball team well
I'm not the principal owner I'm brother
yeah yeah and we had a great group but
for me living in Atlanta as a basketball
fan I was a season ticket holder for
years first and then I was a consultant
to the team so I got to fall in love
with the players the coaching staff
management first and now to be part of
the ownership group with my wife and
four
it's in a city that I live in yeah in a
team that I love yeah it's like you know
it's just it's just unbelievable is I
was talking to my wife the other day I
said you know for my father and my
family and my friends and the city
there's 80 plus games a year where I
could put the teet nights a year I could
put the TV on mmm think about you as a
Knick fan yeah multiply it by 20 and
just you know as and just really love it
so it's been super exciting and I think
we got a really bright future so I'm
looking forward to to the next couple of
years I know it was a little before your
time of owning the Hawks but how is
Dominique Wilkins not in the Hall of
Fame and I love niek house that kind of
the whole thing he deserves to be he
deserves to be he's uh not only a great
basketball player but he's in Atlanta
he's you know he's just a big part of
the of the community so if he's a part
of the a does the play but he's um he
was at every game seiyya I've never seen
him saying no to a photo or an autograph
ever never just he makes people feel
really good yeah and he's very
approachable yeah what are you guys
doing over there to just bring all of
the things that you've talked about here
into the game and make it fun and add
some of the other stuff that's not part
of the 48 minutes like you know the Go
New York's going I think there's several
buckets there's the internal bucket and
Tony wrestlers the principal owners done
an amazing job of just we have a new
practice facility that's
state-of-the-art best probably one of
the best in the NBA we're renovating the
arena massive multi hundred million
dollar renovation that's going on now so
there's a whole there's like the
internal stuff and then there's the game
presentation there's so many layers game
presentation there's the actual
basketball side of it there's the nights
that the team doesn't play that the
arena is available we have a concert I
mean it's just there's so many layers of
it yeah but I think at the end of the
day it's about enthusiasm and passion
and just bringing whatever you can to
infuse a culture of think of your
emotional connection to the
next you taught you first thing you said
to me when I walked in you took me to 94
games yeah you remember this I remember
where I was sitting for certain games
you know what you're eating every one
five years ago yeah I don't remember
what I ate last week exact right you
have no idea there's just so much
emotion and if we could bring that same
passion to the community and marry that
with the Atlanta Hawks that's gonna be
super powerful and I think we can annoy
well as a man it's pretty clear you're
bringing that to your life every day
because this was just I mean this flew
by and it's like I could feel it we're
done that's it that's it well you got to
go do Rogen down so I don't want to
steal all your brain power and now
you've got three more hours with Rogan I
sense you're gonna be up to it up to the
challenge you don't even drink caffeine
you just hopped up on coconut water I am
potassium down but you don't even need
bananas anymore Deva neap why would you
eat a banana at this point I did a lot
of bananas I go to well this man it's
been it's been an absolute pleasure I
suspect we will cross paths again
perhaps in Atlanta because even though
we're holding this for a little bit
maybe definitely come watch you all
right we're gonna come to enjoy the
Petersons abandon Atlanta awesome for
more on Jesse you can check out Jesse
it's lucam
[Music]
you